I think when it comes to what's going on
with covid there's a lot we'll talk
about we'll save it for the members uh
portion because we can get into some
harder numbers and and we'll pull up
this Wall Street Journal story which I
can't talk about on YouTube no joke but
I can talk about something that I think
is a ticking time bomb and I'd love to
get your your thoughts on this carol
this is the Nationwide eviction ban is
going to expire this Saturday after
Biden Administration loses fight with
the Supreme Court so uh there it is we
we you know we we're we're talking about
the other day there's millions of people
that are ready to be evicted someone
super chatted us saying that they work
at a bank and the bank is like lining up
evictions and we were like is is there
going to be an intervention to stop the
evictions because if there isn't we're
going to have August of panic where
people are like I got 30 days and then
September 1st of 10 million people
standing in the street saying I don't
live anywhere yeah so there are already
interventions in New York for example
um the New York state government is uh
partnering with an organization to pay
the landlords and that's going to be
amazing because we have you know we just
print more money it's gonna just because
you're gonna get all the money in the
world right they weren't in a budget
crisis before yeah
um so that's what's happening in New
York and I think that's going to happen
in other states also
um but it really also begs the question
why why like we didn't go this route
before like if we're going to just pay
all these people like why didn't we
start doing this earlier and and be able
to evict people and so they can move on
to other homes and pay their rent there
I mean if we're just going to be
throwing money at people like let's get
started because you know what other
countries are doing when businesses was
shut down they would keep paying the
employees the government paid the
employees to not go to the work but if
they quit that business they wouldn't
get paid anymore yeah as opposed to
incentivizing them to quit and not go
back to work which we've done in the
United States yeah and the businesses
were shut down you know so these
restaurants would have twenty thousand
dollars worth of food in their fridges
and then they'd close for even if even
if it was 15 days all that food spoils
they couldn't sell it and now they're in
the hole 20 and they're in the reopening
some of them and they're like okay guys
come back to work and the people are
like no I'm getting paid to stay at home
dude the most brutal story was when they
reopened and then quickly shut down so
there was like there was one story about
a New York uh restaurant where they were
like we re we we all are spoiled we got
rid of it all they said we are reopening
so then we brought we ordered you know
another twenty thousand dollars worth of
food to get everything back back and
ready to go and then they announced
there was like a halt and they were
going to shut back down or something and
then all the food spoils again and it is
just beating small businesses over that
over and over and over again is this
like another transfer of wealth to now
to landlords like they're sending
governments landlords are still in the
hole what are they going to pay the back
rent yeah
so like the story today was uh one
landlord was owed 28 000 and they sent
him twenty four thousand but but they're
going to look into why they didn't send
the other four thousand and then resend
it to him so yeah yeah I don't
understand how it's happening I don't
understand how there's anywhere near
enough money for it but because then
next month there's going to be a bunch
of people didn't pay this month and
they're gonna have to do it again yeah
yeah it's like we don't we really don't
learn so oh you know I I think
I don't think they they realized or
maybe they did maybe it's the great
reset that you can't just stop an
economy it's a freight yeah yeah what
you ever I think I think I used this
analogy before it was the movie Hancock
with Will Smith
uh a part of it Jason Bateman's car
stops in the tracks and he can't get out
and the train's coming so Hancock lands
flips his car out of the way and then
the train hits him and he doesn't move
so the train just crumples and then
every car flies up in the air because
that energy is gonna go somewhere and
then they're all just like dropping and
crashing that's what happened so this
idea that we can just be like okay
starter back up you know turn the key
and then the economy is going to go it's
not going to happen right I write about
small businesses a lot I had a column
this week about how uh a lot of the tech
firms are already pushing back their
coming back date it was supposed to be
September which is already you know so
such a long time away even now but
they're already moving to October and
Twitter said that they're not even
opening their offices for a while no
they close they're close yeah yeah so
there's a bunch of you know businesses
that support those big businesses
um you know the the bodega and the halal
cart guy and the you know the shoe
Shiner and the dry cleaner and everybody
on that street and they're all paused
waiting for normalcy to return and these
companies are like I don't know maybe we
will maybe we won't you know we'll see
it's really it's really interesting I
think a lot of younger people especially
the Democrat voters because they skew
younger or at least there's more younger
people they don't understand basic
economics like a city with no industry
eventually dies out because no money is
coming in supermarkets small businesses
don't survive because they're usually
you know providing a service to an
existing infrastructure so what happens
is exactly what you said Twitter says we
are closing our offices in New York
what's below the Twitter office probably
a Bodega Restaurant who are their
customers employees of Twitter we're
going to lunch now the office is closed
no names there's not even going to be
another business that comes in to
replace it so now the local corner store
has no one in the area no one's at work
so they shut down and it's going to
Ripple across the board then they pay
these landlords they give people free
money they give people free money they
just keep giving free money but you know
free money is a ticket to extract
resources without providing resources
that imbalance cannot be corrected
there's no key to just turn the engine
how to fix that yeah to me that sounds a
little bit like they expect you to be
able to travel back in time and just
like they thought it would be really
simple to shut down the economy it seems
to me like they also think it's going to
be really simple to just open it up
again yeah just start it up again but
but so they're doing these these
emergency things in New York but are
they doing it anywhere else I don't know
um this was just announced today in New
York so I don't last minute save
I have to imagine that there's a lot of
states that aren't going to get these
bailouts yeah and we're going to see
millions of people without homes I
wonder at what point people just start
saying
I don't care what you say anymore you
know we're I'm already seeing
because DC lockdown tons of people
tweeting they don't care what they say
they're not gonna apply by the stuff and
I'm like at a certain point people just
say enough
and I I hope you're right I just I have
seen nothing I'm not talking from my
fellow Americans this year especially
for my fellow New Yorkers to suggest
that people are going to take any kind
of stands well New York
but I mean like a year ago I thought for
sure if schools didn't open in New York
if Public Schools didn't open in New
York but private schools did open in New
York I was like oh the parents are gonna
Riot are you kidding the private
school's open but the public school's
done no nobody said anything yeah I feel
like uh you know we're out in the middle
of nowhere
and part of me is like I was mentioning
there earlier it's I'm sitting here
saying like I wonder the chickens are
doing you know because they don't they
don't they don't care about this that
makes sense to me they're going there
they're eating food they lay eggs I know
what's going on I look at the news I
have no idea I'm wondering how many
people are just going to continue to
evacuate these cities are going to keep
leaving because we've heard about the
Exodus I'm wondering why you're still in
New York well we would have never left
before the pandemic I mean I knew I
lived in a super leftist place but at
least like it was a competent City I
mean it was it was going so well that we
elected Bill de Blasio twice like that's
how well things were going that we just
didn't care like who was mayor
um but after this year uh we lived in
Florida for almost five months and it
was an oasis of sanity and now we're
definitely thinking about making it a
permanent move I mean it's hard you had
your vision of your life we were going
to live in Brooklyn raise our kids there
retire to Manhattan and now it's like oh
we're gonna move to a different state
entirely it's tough West Virginia is
pretty nice I need an ocean I need an
ocean yeah well it's not too far away
it's like an hour but uh so uh you know
Bill de Blasio said voluntary phase is
over yeah so are you guys is that is
that an is that a a factor I mean it
it's not from you know about the
vaccines like I said I'm vaccinated my
husband's vaccinated but no but it's
like the political no yes it is it is
crazy um I also just don't believe him
the voluntary case is over yeah because
he's like he's paying the biggest goof
like he's just you know and what's crazy
is he actually did a better job
throughout the pandemic than Governor
Cuomo but Cuomo was like the hero of the
pandemic but de Blasio was actually if
you if you look at them side by side I
mean they're both like terrible but de
Blasio did better yeah yeah de Blasio is
probably kicking himself for not
murdering those 15 000 people like homo
did right that's something Cuomo got
away with certainly that was a factor I
can't I can't believe that I'm I'm yeah
I'm still I sit here every every day I
wake up and I'm like
and nobody cares he was warned not to do
it he could have put him in the Javits
Center or the Mercy Hospital vessel and
he said no I'm going to put him in
nursing homes yeah because he didn't
want to give Trump the win dead well now
Bill de Blasio is giving people 100
bucks NYC to pay Big Apple locals 100
for first coveted vaccine injection what
I think this
this people and I'm sorry all right you
know like they did lotteries there are
some people you're not going to convince
yeah I think the hundred dollars might
get a lot of people though I agree yeah
I think people will motivate to go again
I think that the fact that they're still
at like vaccination centers not in your
doctor's office really does deter people
so if they're paying a hundred dollars I
guess they'll go stand you know they'll
go to get some random location and get
their vaccination there but
um it is creepy it's very creepy that
they need to be handing out hundred
dollar bills are they paying people that
already got vaccinated in retrospect no
well but what is dirty what if someone
goes to one of these vaccinations and
says like oh I never got it but they did
because I want 100 bucks yeah I think is
there a date I mean I don't even know is
there a database like there's no
database to check whether I don't know
yeah I assume there would be and in the
future this would be incentive to like
say no I'm not gonna get it and wait
until they start bribing for sure right
right who's gonna get like the booster
for example until they give me like a
thousand dollars yeah yeah it's like
you're you're flying a plane and they're
like we are overbooked
you know last time I flew it was like
they go to a thousand dollars wow so you
know what I would do is when they would
say like here's our offer I would go up
and be like double it yeah and be like
done here you go and I'd be like all
right and then I just feel like I'm
gonna sit here for a few hours I'm good
you know should you also get the food
voucher right and like a hotel voucher
you can get it to go oh yeah depending
on how long you get delayed you can also
be like I I once was just like can I get
first class on the next flight and
they're like yes sir wow and I was like
yes
they have to get you off that plane yeah
so anyway yes people are going to be
like oh they want boosters now let's
let's wait it out and see how much we
can get out of this guy the less of us
that go the faster they'll start driving
us that might not work out dude I I
wonder if the main problem is that
there's just too many people
just in general it's poorly organized
because well how do you how do you
organize millions and millions and
millions of people on the internet as
like I was just thinking about this if
we did have some sort of like debt
Revolution or something where people
either refuse to pay their debts or they
defaulted on Federal Reserve um interest
or whatever we would that wouldn't be
enough a chaotic Revolution would just
be Madness we'd have to like create a
new constitution maybe using the Manila
principles factoring in the internet
using cryptocurrency building a new
economy all at once if there was a
change we'd have to have the structure
in place like the founding fathers did
we're there we're close to it the Manila
principles are legit cryptocurrency is
amazing I just think about how like a
lot of our our structures in terms of
Congress and and voting was built around
a substantially smaller amount yeah less
technology like sending like feather
writing things on with feathers and
sending on horses no IDs took two months
to get messages to England to back right
you know what always tripped me out is
like I was watching uh Pirates of the
Caribbean and it's like the opening
scene in the first movie where Jack
sparrows on the boat isn't sinking and
he lands and then they're like What's
your name and he's like I'll pay you if
you don't ask why just tell them Bill
Smith yeah he does say Smith though but
like yeah just you can just walk and be
like hi I'm I'm you know John Smith yeah
there you go prove it what are you gonna
do about it and then he's like oh no
he's been branded or whatever but yeah
it was that's that's the that's that's
one thing people need to understand is
like uh I was talking about this earlier
the reason why you had to own land in
order to vote was mostly because there
were no IDs and your tie to the
community was the fact that you lived
there and they didn't want people to
show up who didn't live there vote for
things and then leave that was part of
it obviously there were still a lot of
old patriarchal structures and things
like things like that but there's I
think the changes that came about with
universal suffrage made sense in that
we're no it's we're not buying land
anymore we live in New York we rent it a
lot most people are renters so you know
they vote in that capacity but things
were so dramatically different back then
I wonder if we got to get back to uh
people kind of spread out get out of
these cities learn some personal
responsibility I don't know yeah I mean
the thing is that the cities were doing
so great until they weren't right so
it's it's like it almost kind of shows
that like the cities have have had their
moment but
um I don't know I mean you really want
people moving out here like oh that's a
good point yeah yeah well I mean
it's not about too close it's about like
there's there's lot sizes it's like so
you know if they like there's a few
Acres around where it's like where we
have our our space we have more space
than a city yeah would I want to live
you know uh in Philadelphia we had half
we had half an acre for the whole house
so the front yard was a third The House
of the third the backyard was the third
and you couldn't do a whole lot I mean
we could skate in the backyard and we'd
have a mini ramp but we could only do it
between certain hours because the
neighbors would be like too late too
early now we can go out at one in the
morning and scream at the top of our
lungs and there are people who live too
far away they don't care some days
you'll be sitting there and you'll hear
bangs you'll hear gunshots and you're
just like hunting again you just turn
your coffee Brooklyn too yeah yeah I
lived I lived on the uh uh on
um right off Myrtle and Nostrand that's
where that cops got assassinated I'd be
the reason one of the reasons I didn't
know what happened when it happened so
like I'm sitting in my bed I get a text
message are you near the assassinations
and I'm like what happened it was like
one of my bosses at fusion and then I
look out the window and I see cops
everywhere it's because I'm sitting
there all day and I hear gunshots all
the time and I'm just like sitting there
pow pow pow and I'm like dude like you
know whatever I don't know this is
welcome to New York you know what I mean
and New York's not even that bad yeah
yeah Chicago yeah I thought La was
amazing before the pandemic I was like
as we develop electric cars we're going
to get all these gas guzzlers off the
road La is going to be a paradise and
then but I knew in the back of my head
the central electric grid and water grid
were very very tenuous because if some
sort of cataclysm or disaster caused the
water grid to break and the electric
grid to break those people would have
started cannibalizing each it would have
been Terror on Earth yeah and I think
covid was gave us kind of an early
warning sign for sure of the danger of
being packed together in cities with a
centralized you know importing your
water and your food and your electricity
we could like
decentralize the water to each each
house could have their own water pump
you know electrical yeah and food grow
your own food I mean it's pretty a
drastic change right but until that I
don't see the value of living in a city
yeah I think I think now cities cause
cultural Decay at least they do now I
think before there used to be hubs of
culture because you'd live outside the
city you'd have very little contact then
you'd go into the City and you'd see
things you'd talk to people you'd learn
things and it was like that's where the
stuff was happening you know you know my
favorite movie to cite in this regard is
the movie The Patriot with Mel Gibson
because it's a great movie I love it but
it's like there's a scene where he's
like the kid's like are we going to
Charlestown like we're going to town
like yeah and now it's like oh Town it
smells like sour milk there's traffic
everywhere I are I I don't need to be
there it's hard to eat it's hard to sit
restaurants in New York I don't I you
know what I think back to living there
and I understood why I wanted to live
there when I first I remember the first
time I went to New York it was just it
was during occupied by Wall Street and I
took a bus from Virginia
and I remember finally getting to New
York City and I can't remember I have no
idea which Bridge we were crossing I
can't remember and then I see the city
in the buildings and I'm like holy
I'm from Chicago and New York has five
Chicago's so I remember you're driving
downtown you see all the buildings and
it's like I'm used to that New York was
something else I'm like I want to live
here it's like being downtown Chicago
everywhere
and then after a few years I was like
you want to go to a restaurant you're
crammed in the corner in this tiny seat
with your shoulders like this and you're
like thanks for the food there's no room
so I'm exaggerating obviously but it's
like it's congested it stinks there's
nowhere to park Transportation the
trains are are often crowded and smelly
and I used to love all of this I used to
love every single thing about it like I
I really was such a New York supremacist
I like really thought it was the
greatest place ever and I I still like
you know it's really hard it's like I
can always compared to like letting go
of like a really good relationship but
like it just isn't working out for you
um yeah I don't know I if covet had
never happened I would be here like
being like New York is the best you
don't [ __ ] with New York sorry what was
your first experience seeing in
Manhattan
um so I I grew up in Brooklyn so
um I don't really remember you know I
feel bad for you know why
you you there's a lot of people like
growing up in Chicago
I got to experience the first time
seeing a city as it was New York but for
someone who's from there there's no
point where you're going to see
something I guess you go to Tokyo right
you know yeah that's crazy it's crazy
dude I had the most nut ball experience
with New York City I moved to Queens I
I'd been through Manhattan when I was
younger but I took the subway into
Manhattan for the first time I walked
out of the subway oh my God and looked
up and it was just 90 story skyscrapers
all around me and I could feel like the
vacuum and like yeah I was being sucked
up and away it was so bizarre man what a
city I I do think that Tim is right
sorry I have to say this real fast I
think that Tim is right and I think that
cities have become too crowded I think
too many people live in one place at one
time it becomes very insular so instead
of being like a cultural center you just
get like an echo chamber and also when
something goes wrong it affects a
thousand more people than it would
otherwise right very much effect it's
like a ripple effect and it's
exponential in a city and just this
moment of Conformity
um cities have really not uh been a
great place to be when everybody has to
think the same there isn't that you know
diversity of thought or just a lot of
great culture going on because
everybody's exactly the same and you can
only be one way and like comedy has to
be very very muted and all of it really
just sucks and it's it's it is
definitely a problem that is centered on
cities but it's a problem that we're
having I think all across the country I
think one of the issues is that when you
get uh complete one-party rule there's
no way to challenge bad ideas yep so the
people in power are like Hey we're going
to lock everyone down and shut your
businesses down and you agree because
you're a Democrat right you're not a
republican are you and they go I'm not a
republican I'm gonna wear the mask so
that no one thinks I'm a republican
right so saith David Hogg and then
you'll get Cuomo being like I'm gonna
put people in nursing homes and kill 15
000 people and then they're like well
he's a Democrat so it must be okay yeah
and then they find out that he like
Abused Women and they all freak out and
like oh no what do we do that's the one
thing we're not supposed to then they
like didn't and then the Freak Out was
very short-lived and then they were like
but he's a Democrat so it's okay and I'm
a Democrat so it's okay thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time